[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طالب بيت انا مش اقدر انه بيت يديني
اولادي وسلم هذا البيت للاوقاف وارحم
القبور من العذاب تبعنا لانه القبور تعبوا
اصلا اقول لك يخلف عليهم ان القبور
استحملونا يخلف عليهم البني ادمين اللي
برا ما استحملوناش هم استحملونا يمكن احنا
نرحمهم لما نطلع من هنا نلحمهم من اولادنا
كلهم بالكامل لانه هذا مش حياه
[موسيقى]
مخاطرها كتير
زي ما انتم شايفين
قصه صعبه بس خلاص اقلمنا الموضوع
بسكن هنا في الاوقاف بنطلع رزقه لانه احنا
ساكنين اموات بنشربه وبناكل وبنتغسل على
الاموات وربنا كيف بده يجازينا ربنا قال
ما فيها رزقنا اول حاجه
عشان هيك احنا
ملناشد الحكومه وزاره الاوقاف انه تشوف
لنا حل
[تصفيق]
بيبيع المخدرات على باب ضربك اطلع اتكلم
يا راجل اللي يقول لي بدي احط لك شفره
على اولادي خايف بطلعهمش من قلب الدار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]